we said relations are special kind of
equation functions are a special kind of
relation of the unity but inside where
we think of those Reimer how many
variables in relation how how many
points 2 2 2 2 right the two variables
are thought of as now this is a really
important idea and it's really triggered
focus on what we look at in study the
two variables are thought of and input
which is the X and output which is the Y
and once you think of they're not is
just to separate connected ideas one of
them leads to another one and each input
has one output and one over okay now
this is a weird definition so the best
way to think about it is in contrast to
what it's not have a look at these five
relations that we've already drawn okay
remember I said you functioned our
special kind of relation most of the
things you draw here are functions
except for one subtle goodness right if
this is the input this is the output
input/output you put in an X how many
values of y do you get out exactly one
right it exact in just the same way if
you put in a value of x here we put in
an angle you'll get out exactly one y
value right sine of thirty degrees in
earlier ha it's not like a couple of
different things
I can keep going through this until you
then get to this guy right you supply an
X like say x equals zero when x equals
zero
how many Y's do you do the answer is
more than one right why can you plus a
later on
this breaks our definition right you got
input
you've got an output but some of your
inputs not all of the binary some of
your inputs have multiple outputs just
look back at a circle there are some
requests exactly - is that did you give
you exactly one output where are they
you see x equals negative 1
you see that's got exactly one output
namely zero and x equals one also has
exactly one output but doesn't matter
that somewhere it's okay we needed to
have it everywhere okay each input
exactly one output all the time okay so
maybe up on their next your table you
want to label for out of these five are
functions these guys are functions they
are also relation functions are a
special kind of relation but because
they are more specific we can say it's
just like squared and rectangles like if
I showed you this that is a rectangle I
mean assuming everything is you know
properly drawn but you wouldn't call the
rectangle you'd call the square right so
being that these are more special we
call them functions not just relations
the idea in only relation done and fit
the definition or a function did you
ever pressure
yeah oh graduate like that
okay so along with this idea here where
what is it he put that one out for we
introduce new language and new notation
okay so we say Y is a function of X
right Y is a function of X
he's your input right he's your output
you can say this in other ways too you
can say temperature is a function of
altitude does that make sense if you
know where you are you can with some
certainty work out what temperature you
are the high
contents we say Y is the function X the
way we write this you ever I showed you
this before that I said look that's a
relation right if I want to make
specific that I'm talking about this in
function terms because that is also a
function I would write this like this
and this is weird
there are things to dislike about this
notation but it's so important and so
useful for other purposes what that's
worth swallowing the problems okay
I wish you have a look at the left-hand
side of that equation if you didn't know
any of this what would that look like to
you the left-hand side doesn't it look
like Y times X in brackets what it looks
like right what you've been trained to
think of it as but in function notation
we read that as Y is a function of X and
this is what the function is this is how
I define it okay I can tell you in all
kinds of ways for example I could say
this what do you think that means what
the area of a circle is a function of
its radius and this is what that
function is okay there are other things
you need to budget them but you might
have to say this
how would you read that
my look-look thing which is the right
hand side this is a both of you volume
is a function of the radius and the
height and this is what that function is
defined as does that make this where's
the cheeky looking at that area where
you've got one input and one output the
question is the volume ones of the node
doesn't that make three okay so this is
where this is why I said not to write it
this language does get becomes so useful
to papal it gets borrowed by all other
kinds of versions of math and science as
well so what we're looking at out a
rigorous definition is just one input
justice one output
okay which keeps things nice and simple
but you can still do lots and lots of
interesting competent okay okay now this
notation here I want to stay on this
straight which we met functions so often
your functions will not be called why
they'll be called F and you guess is
what the S stands for function okay so
this is a function
I'm calling it f you can call it
anything you like you can call that
function Eric if you want I mean other
than one it works but you can't okay
okay I could say Eric is a function of X
you had Eric a number and then Eric does
this stuff to that number right so for
example I'm just going to rocket it I
could say Eric of five what would that
mean I would take the number five and I
place it into the function in place of X
so it would be five squared plus five
squared plus six seven would be 56 area
to five is to six
you don't have to put just numbers in it
you can put in other algebra so for
example you could go area under this is
just too much fun so now I'm Eric of
eight plus five right so all that would
mean is everywhere X or X I'm going to
put in n plus five I'm not going to
expand this but it would be a plus five
squared plus five months of April time
plus six
you're great
and I'm definitely gonna stop here but
the thing is you can put anything into
you you could even put in other
functions don't think too hard about
what that means okay
but although Romania is the Cawood
expensive sign is persist that's what
this function is right well now I'm
going to put that back into itself I
guess in this case a little rider this
would be x squared plus 5x plus 6
squared plus 5 lots of x squared plus 5x
plus 6 plus 6
zamak that yeah don't do that okay so my
point is you can and in some contexts
canary calculus this idea of this input
and output machine I'll become
incredibly powerful okay